[Music]
so hello everyone good evening how was
the date if you watch the games you got
fun back here with the my favorite let
your end game exclam here at San Luis
chess club so I kind of go back to the
night and games what the inspired Minh
was getting a lot of endings in the
branches to the past couple of days and
we will see love moments a lot of drama
me stood mr. draw mr. Wynn and with with
clerks with clock's ticking and few
seconds left and said oh wow how could
they miss Oh top players but it's really
really really really hard and I had few
examples some of these positions from
past unable to see how and again keeps
repeating itself so we can see again
they're all off classics and the more
you study the more examples you see the
better your often it's never enough to
see more even if it's in a definitive
form and you'll never run out of endgame
material you might think that it's kind
of restricted in a way but it's very
different thought ok let's have a look
at this one what was so specific those
who were here last time about the night
and game as we were talking one very
important fact about the knife in games
that's very important one that applies
its and it's because you're dealing with
knife that cannot lose cannot lose a
temple
because of that the night any games have
very very rare characteristics that we
sign generally when we deal with night
end games whether against night versus
not night versus Bishop you get to see a
lot of exceptions about the Barbie night
end game so let's have a look at this
position it's white to move obviously
the King on f5 is shouldering or edging
or what are the other terms they use for
it
shouldering edging out flanking all
those stuff they use that King on h4 but
there is a so much material lift and
black kind of has some sort of activity
here so how do we approach this position
let's say give you a few minutes to
think about it
thank you furnish but that lasts because
it very very for concrete race tonight
yeah that's it
softer every minister well that isn't
your night is kind of tight not to see
it because that is life under Congress
defunded who did nighttime you ever take
that
any foreigners its protective yes we
also have to realize that King Amish
work does not disappear forever try to
move from walk over oh I move forward I
will sit forward we'll move to the
inside where the g3 s3 all the way to to
defend so it's not a simple long can we
good here can get for King h5 yeah well
the thing is that all these are squares
as GM car similar and diversity all the
scores in mind you cannot go to any
other business course so basically by
elimination to go forward that's the
only square you have so you can go King
g6 and now what happens of the Kings you
for
[Music]
give you seven and the beauty that I
don't have also kinky five so if I go
can get four
in candy for
see the problem
we want to be sixty four-bit then we
wanted to be like oh it will have been
fantastic yet we still have another
score right so King t6v foreign King c6
now let's say if I if I make a moving
mine I just need to 97 there's no nice
right pause we prefer multi night before
just go grab the other part okay
speaking of unique ability of night and
unique problem of nights
yesterday and so Nakamura had almost
goes far right very close to win was a
pawn up night endgame the mission had no
target yet because there wasn't enough
material on the board failed to convert
I was technically this is easy but even
when the night Dominus the bishop in
that game that position he was his King
was actually dominating blacks King but
even when the knife dominates the bishop
it's not that is even with the material
up and I was thinking okay I've seen
something similar before what I just
couldn't recall and I figured out I have
this beautiful game from yeah this is
fine 2011 on on versus to fall off in an
Amber blind falling from Monaco and
let's have a look at this position yeah
this is not blind fault okay
this is the position and as you can see
white is of a pawn right
what is ever pond the night dominates
the bishop and black king is absolutely
just black has only one defense and
that's passive defense yet it takes a
long way to convert this position first
of all we have to consider whether if we
take on c6 or not
why not hmm
that says after King v6 what they do
Bishop we should be six losses to night
night the seven check that's the problem
after q2f 76 and you don't have enough
time to to stop promotion so if king c6
their King v6 Bishop e1 because we
should be 697
so
but what happens after we should be one
just before that submissions c6
fish up - this should be 495 check now
can't capture that right what's that
53 the problem is that if you don't get
to be seven there's a problem our Bishop
is on on average on the rod under the
shore tag on sorry this still short
diagonal so if you go over 53 I think I
have a night night
I can play c7 we should be six and let's
have a look right let's have a look at
that so if we should be three I think I
can play 97 check first
oh that's right well because you also
have King has you cannot go to have
seven you cannot go to so you have to go
to g7 and now I think I have enough time
to play c7 right oh nice - if I was
easier yep I see five because because
now I have this check actually only six
and that's funny
I think c7 Bishop e6 King g7 was also
winning but that's just a
straightforward one so that's how to
pull off miss the chance but the move
was of course Bishop before and after
ninety five years this actually we don't
capture we don't capture actually
because if you capture now taking g7
King g5 we lose their position if you
take I just didn't calculate that
because take King takes nine King g7
King g5 can be eight and this is always
opposition
but after Bishop before yeah we can go
can give 7-6 mm but this is what I think
the score of the ring the bell from
yesterday's game the sport of high pick
Bishop on h8 we'll look at that later
so you can the questions that can I get
to play my lipsticks check that's the
question
but everybody knows the answer not why
yes because if it doesn't work in this
position then you can not put me in a
soup salon to get that same position the
night camp cannot do the tempo so this
is a draw if this position is a draw you
cannot maneuver along with the night and
try to get the position that is winning
so but the questions are how could what
win in this position and it's actually
it takes like 10 15 moves to win well 10
most away
I never most should be very accurate
well the moment you have not well don't
you have 97 let's say Bishop - well this
d5 then I have you can up to 95 by the
way obviously right so you have to
maneuver your King somewhere next to g5
and I give it shake but then you'd have
no access to c6 let's just say pass it
with my team gonna fake that correct so
we want to take a challenge I find a win
it's a ten mohs win we can write down
the date but write it down I actually
feel very bad I was I think I was
preparing for the World Cup
I had a match against the English is
that what what what year which is 12 is
it in March 14 I'm not sure if it's
European or I serve I think I think it's
in March so if it was in March I was
preparing for my match against two
English in the World Cup and I think I
was doing some tactic and it was one of
the physicians and I didn't find
actually so
so well where do you watch this I play I
play Bishop Bishop somewhere we should
be three you can put you're not on g6
the more you're not design b6 my picture
is going to be on d5 on my kingdom going
to be on FA and if if I have seven
obviously I'm not going to take because
you take em [ __ ] g6 then won't you
play of seven I'm just breaking this 7
so the idea of combining to maneuver to
18-gauge six you want to support your
pawn and also attacking the pawn on c6
you have to combine both idea at the
same time if you don't do that if you do
want to do one at a time you cannot win
the game if you have to do some sort of
a backward induction you have to see the
final position and then try to build it
from from scratch you have to see the
one position you have to envision the
final position first
actually my mistake was at a time when I
was trying to see it all the way through
and get the winning position but it's
easier if you envision the winning
position and then try to move backwards
well the first one is obviously 97 oh ok
let's set plate reshipped is we should
we should be 6 losses immediately just
you know there are tactic I well as you
were cap you're calculating it's not
only just about where I put my pieces
tactics matter too so for example we
should be six losers immediately to king
c6 right that is depending the pot so we
should be five not this position
obviously cannot improve unless you play
King g5 so this is also a forced move on
this clicking get now you have to think
about where you want up with your knife
now it's the moment now you're in
complete control while completely
dominates the position the King 95 the
Knights can couple you anywhere you want
you have a pawn on f6 well put my bishop
on f3
dat 635 well I was not g5 because you're
not close enough to the opponent c6 so
you can't eliminate that you're not
close enough to c6 right yeah well if
I've been here yet if I if I v8 or Cordy
6 yeah ah you know if you get a position
within that kink on g6 910 v6 I can not
sure if let's say you have your king
over here I can let me let me fill in
your position will get back here if you
get their King I think I'm right but
just could make sure about that even if
you get this position with the bishop on
g5 and it's black to move I think I can
take on epsilon here can you just call
the engines here just to make sure I
just can't wait oh I can just wait I
cannot take on f7 can't I I uh I go back
to b7 okay I can see b7 okay but maybe
thing is a draw even this is a draw I
knew that it's a dry forget about it but
yeah so even this position if you get it
to have to play of seven without a
support for a fitness square is a draw
well let's do it
go ahead make some moves 98 3 5 ok a six
yeah let's say here before
go here III
yeah well I can fight another round to
f2
I get it from g4 or PG 3 final because
stop now and 5
and okay well that's okay I can still
flip between ng vibrate kimchi five find
out now and as hard to get sex queries
in the right way in
it looks very simple active white
completely dominates right you have your
any absolute control of everything but
if anyone tries in practice it's not a
zani right yeah yeah like a non-stop 96
could I scrap 94 at all
I mean I could go be sure to three then
you can put anything yeah so let's say I
keep let's I keep waiting okay you got
the desired position so go yeah well we
can't get now okay that's makes sense
yeah yeah let's say well actually I
can't play Bishop reform but let's
actually be sugar three I want this what
happens 96 we shift to go G to nah let's
just I please make it a little difficult
so because we're sure making all the way
to the file and over to and yeah
or I don't think that's policy upon a
state now so yeah Tina for all the way
around the 85 yeah there's this if you
if you get here yeah this is can I go
around here let's find out its King III
yeah yeah this is winning this is
winning but the question is that the
question is I worked if I just to stage
when you take like flicking c6 okay
before I just put this guy over here
okay
but now you can go check and now you can
go chicken king g6 that's not lying yeah
well then you take on c64 the tempo well
but the question is that here is of this
move maybe I could produce produce much
after this yeah I go there as you can
see we still don't have a win yes or d7
yes that's strictly well just you
promote to win yes that's it three
that's why we just decided that it came
should be on fh3
f7 we don't come with a tempo now that
we know already since the presentation
yeah that's it they're basically had
that bishop state and anywhere along
that HHH one diagonal to power to make
it draw because you would provoke c7 and
they can get be sure it's three that's
exactly what we look at next that is
Nakamura against Garry Kasparov that's
the next game we're looking at well we
can't play you can play actually ideas
with the f7 on King g6 can get six
that's also an idea
then after camp then I can play then I
can then where's your king should be
that's a good that's a good point but
then when you play 98 the King goes to
eat Val your king should be your king
should be on hh6
that so you have to have your king
honest taste in the night and v8 if
black nut doesn't try anything then your
kingdom money we're back to b6 and
that's how you win good let's have a
look at it yes what let let's have a
look at it okay all right
this is faster Knight b6 not B it is
also winning not be just a few moves
faster we look at ninety eight to ninety
six okay the bishop has to move let's
say Bishop g8 loses just so fast because
King goes to now the bishop doesn't get
to get to that diagonal the hh1
a a diagonal so it is just at least an
under so I grab the pot so Bishop of 398
so I go there for now now I move my king
97 I go to d8 and now but this and now
98 there can get 6 the night and the 8
and the King ganas 6 doesn't matter if
that King gonna pay the same then you
can maneuver back your king or you can
play we have 7 our King g7 so we should
be v f7 and then that's winning just
right it is promote upon and again the
most simple what I forgot again is that
I in this position then that goes here
to b7 I actually hope you wish you had
didn't have the pollen c6 year if you
remove the part from c6 I click zoom v v
c6 King to b6 or if the night b7 King to
c6 because you always want another rule
of right angles remember the night
always wants to support the pawn from
behind from Bab so if we don't be united
on h4 you want and your pawn is on h3
one point at g2 and h4 so that way the
King cannot interfere so let's have a
look at night night be tonight that one
is more instructive in a sense this one
is faster but it involves a lot of
tactics small tactics tonight 98 this it
doesn't matter you should G to 96 so we
did that when you were actually 96 there
so we first got an idea but the point is
that the point is that we get their
weight well he want this mother so 6
walk ok but I want to see ok the other
way around
this is nice nice here it took b6 as my
own analysis and some is faster but this
one I think I saw it in the book - I
think it goes with the sixth one so if
we just want to create this one you kind
of have to really pay attention because
always as we discussed there are only
certain positions that are six one does
not cannot do the temple you cannot just
move to Bishop it's not like bishop we
just won't allow the diagonal so I think
with the bishop on d5 is is a
is a six while yeah because not the
visual estimate equal king b6 King f6
and exhibition wants to see poetic mind
c6 if the special was anywhere else it
wouldn't have been six o'clock right I
just multiplied bishop and then because
I get there and if and if King b7 and
can give five in maneuvering I think you
finally get to have the night to be 6
and then the bishop finally that's the
point is dat squared is these one of my
analysis I think somebody had problem
two dancing around with the night so
they took their time but you take the
keys we get the score and the 1986 98
you can get six well this was whole lot
more complicated than a sports game but
the idea of the key square for the
knight and the kids school for the King
and how you want to push the pawn is is
it is the main one so if you want to
look here listen so let's have a look
how things one's a little bit wrong for
so I just to for the benefit of everyone
I just really like this i wiii make you
more most we don't care about this part
because this is not okay this is
actually a very interesting anything i
was looking at but it's very complex and
that is not related to our topic so i'll
leave it for next week maybe so we get
this position okay what nights are very
mysterious what can we do now f6 right
obviously king takes f6 doesn't work and
if King takes here and wins the body
will show one temple
they're the so we ship to see five of
seven now f80 the threat King goes back
now we have this position what's the
right winning planted not just most just
what is the what is the right attitude
towards winning this position because
the glass of the ape on the grass are
supporting arepa why a pond if the
parmesan before or c4 surprisingly is
not winning because you cannot create
because if the pond was on v7 you'll
have a king on 695 King be a bishop g3
same story if you want to bring your
king to a7 the bishop goes back to b8
you cannot improve here well the thing
is that that is wrong that position if
the pause well nh4+ and nh3 because then
you can go wind you can play 96-97
promote and then come back into h h4
pond so the position is winning but with
the pond with the a pond if in your king
is on b7 you can so let's say your king
is advanced enough to shoulder blacks
King from from approaching the pond if
the powers on b7
you couldn't win on the B file but
because it's a file we place 86 and you
put in item b6 and then you kill any
other plan of Bishop getting to the part
that couldn't have happened with the
problem b7 but the promotion square is
of the same color and if the phone is on
c6 that's a good process the point is on
c6 are if the powers on c6 you actually
could win again let's have a look at it
I'm discussing this position well I was
just looking at if this could be member
if the promise were there
if the pawns were there you could just
put it 95 + C 7 the right moment win the
peace and then and then and then come
back to your knife and I actually showed
in when we go back to because parts came
I'll show how that wins and then night
come night comes faster than the King to
win the pot on h4 and that's winning
so this position this is a draw yes
twice the points on a six because my
king cannot be close enough
that's why so let's look at that so
that's that's winning
so King c4 was the winning move and
another important thing is that my King
gets to be seven right on time
and he's helps a lot that you can win
the Polish for well if the pawn was on
h5 if the power was on actually would
have played nice people and you've
supported the pot but then you have to
be careful when you push the pawn
because I might have counsel attack with
King g6 so the final h4 is very helpful
to have it because the moment you grab
the point
the more you attack the pond you grab it
and you can play Neji - you will see why
it matters
this is always winning because if the
pomazan h5 it would have been little
tricky and now that's your question what
do we do
we grab the pond and then always defend
times G 2 under niche for
that's that's uh that's and that's nice
one if the common image five that would
have any problem the problem here is
that when I play this move you won't
play the 16 g6
I can go king c c6 first the problem is
that not even well Bishop e7 then I can
go up to the pawn faster the thing is
that the problem is that I go I collect
this that's the problem and now if you
play King g5 your king is tied down to
the pawn on h4 if you go to try to win
the pawn I can bring the pollen h4 and
many many were denied all the way to the
Queen side and then support my plan to
be promoted and because the pawn doesn't
control the the bishop doesn't control
the promotion square I'll get I get to
pick my pawns to promotions put the
light on b6 King on b7 and the pawn gets
there so yeah but instead found was on
h5 it was still winning I probably have
to play 196 provoke h4 and then go back
to the ninth and then do the same thing
okay the thing is that now I'm switching
to a little bit of Bishop versus Bishop
because the Camorra happens to have
another interesting game third down
against the lake one glim that was a
very interesting game so what's terrific
repeated with pattern in the night
versus nine versus not or nine versus
Bishop endgame there are four four
themes that was repeating itself
my cousin was a tempo you have to
envision the right score for the night
so you have to know where the night
belongs to and it's always comments in a
combination with your king your elves is
usually wants to think about nighttime
pawn you think about knockin King worth
with my king P if my Knights going to be
on the eighth the other night always
nice on behind has to support the pawns
I was the third one was the fourth one
or third one
third one and I like the first one knife
tends to mine a lot of squares so
geometry matters a lot so more than
moving toward or moving away from things
in terms of interests we always like to
the King has to move toward the center
to support things when it comes to
knives just simply see the geometry
because knives just are not very
conventional they're just not moving in
line so just a simple approaching or or
fading away getting away from it doesn't
doesn't doesn't work that way so four
things
the fourth thing is geometry the last
time when I showed you I'll show you at
the end of the class when at the end of
the lecture when geometry matters I
showed a very beautiful study in our
last lecture about the geometry of
knives
so let's have a look at the next
position I never thought this much that
how in bishop and games temple should be
married I always think about the scope
of my bishop if I have another square so
that my bishop can can move along the
diagonal so if it's only two squares
always usually when it comes to Bishop
and pawn versus Bishop when you always
want to have the bishop of the manga
diagonal so if there is going to be a
sort of a bridge that you want to put
the bishop with between the lines there
can be on the right place and you're
visualizing up scores to move so you
won't be in a sort of it Ziggs one but
surprising order and this is one of the
interesting examples I don't know if
there's an other draws I was just happy
to find this fun this is so complex the
taunt impose the Pont NP besides the
game here both lair missed it but this
is just we have a saying in Persian and
then I whisker just it's so it just
happens so beautiful Bishop III and I
was I was when I was looked at it when I
was looking analyzing the computer I
want to see a summit
it's just waste of time the point is
after Bishop takes e - I played Bishop
we want I forced upon most and that one
temple besides the game but let's make
straw I couldn't believe my eyes
a3 King goes to f8 now it doesn't matter
now you only want to create a fortress
h6
and after Bishop now you don't have to
ship d3 because now I can take and then
minus squares White has moved this pawn
to e3
what does have enough tempo it's a draw
unbelievable
so our first thing like this is winning
right and now I play b5 doesn't have
enough Tempe actually now you should be
careful to push the parts correctly
otherwise you lose that is astonishing
this Bishop you what do you think about
primal content in this position now I
just want to have the bishop the right
Square to be to be ready to stop White's
King from when you're wearing to c6
obviously that's where I was wants to
penetrate a later on too so Bishop d3
Bishop takes Bishop b1 a3 well obviously
I mean this trick doesn't work I just
just don't fall for most lucky 7
so a3 can get fate kingi three and a six
and this white simply cannot progress
let's say for example Bishop c4 I look
like we should have played this doesn't
matter
we just don't don't play five to give
this is extra square c5 that may cause
some problem this way and the point is
that if I try too hard
I mean basically go there that it's not
far too hard just doesn't get anywhere
there's no entry that there is were no
pawn on f5 he blundered upon there are
no points
we'll look at that now shortly it is not
actually yes but lake one miss have
these five wins we'll see how much is
that I just say that it's I didn't say
that with few seconds there you really
can can only rely our intuition and and
this position was absolutely calculation
based there is no way that you could
just make a move based on all the cap on
the intuition in my opinion was
impossible so what happened was like you
can expect more than what happened but
yeah that that I deal with b5 actually
was a little bit premature we will look
at that huh
sure so here so so but then I will
realize that this smoke is not a good
mode so we should fix me too
so now what's obvious officially too is
losing for everyone right there's not
enough tempo if you calculate just to
simplify the calculation just came here
can give three King takes six simply
voila smart
what's that
the Parthenon is six that position have
to be should be one be plated six after
we put walked the move a three then five
six
well it's black to move the pawns on
edge 60,000 a three and black goes D
five kills one temple here so let me
show you again
takes well oh yeah this is move and then
Bishop b3 b5 that if you play 16 h3 is
losing you're right about this if I play
a six year white plays h3 and then it's
just losing right everything is
symmetrical the pawn moves just imitate
your opponent's move did blacks move and
and that's it
b5 before a5 a4 h4 h5 that's it however
this kills the symmetry and save the day
because now before
what happened I'm by the way H 5 H is 3
H 4 H 5 first rate
whatever it was which move a 4r that's a
good point actually take take a 5 h 3
losing so so before is not only move
actually swing now black or black now is
winning eyes you have a temple here now
h v 5i goes to a 6 h 3 huh
so let's count it then takes takes a 5
losses change 3 D 6 a 5 inch finish
quality so what about my 6 takes fix and
before
takes takes huh h 4r k h6 that you have
a basic class 1 with this h 5 if H 5 H
for H a 5 if a 5h for yeah yeah just
take yeah yeah this take take n h5 right
yeah 285 H 4 H 3 and if the H for H 8 5
years what's that you're losing
I let me see is it could it be losing
our this is losing actually yeah age 46
because I think I play King f6 and you
are a 6-1 you have to play King gage 605
for when I've taken if I be taking gage
5 up licking f6 and I force it if like
engage 6i and then I don't want apart
here like this you CH for here yeah H
for eyes now I thought you you say what
is for here it's okay ok 5 is 4 yeah
this is is this central yeah it's
winning because I can play King get 4
when you play h3 h6 nice winning because
King g5 I take I'm take king at 4 and
then this is king Gia
draw why Kings you 3 H 4 F 4 stop 1 2 3
F 4
so that's very that 110-foot besides the
whole so anyways he end up in a losing
position now we don't have the pond
let's see if I'm not missing anything
okay ah yeah we should be seven then
yeah king g6 doesn't work King at four
and then I take the part of the play
kingi for but the bishop is badly placed
I can play King q4 and the big view
don't have any check on f3 I can go King
gets five and grab it for nine six so at
six issue what this because I was
looking at it looks very simple I can
get [ __ ] g6 I think that's the first
thing you miss yeah but then I just I
just played before now it's the same
position I played before I played that
first okay if Bishop c6 and I should
actually ever like this I just played
Bishop e2 and after and like I don't
know watching this place should finish
forward that's it I can't even prepare I
I have the luxury of time to prepare
so that was the first time but so so
basically he had to try to go through f5
so here he could play this this and I
think you're sufficiently free now I
want my King go through the five -
unless there is this move
take check another this check it's not
going to be that easy it's not honest
king of City and then I don't need to
lose the pond that's my point is that
can I just Heymann everything on that's
ok this doesn't matter at all what's
that well he was not trying to create
the winning position which was right
here I don't really suppose I and I put
this out okay for example chef c4 was
was a winning move here basically force
to beat one of the pans to move that's
another looks like that Bishop before we
have b5 now your king will cut through
and then if b5 you subscribe Bishop d3
and then King goes to c5 simple it just
mean even even we should beat or nuts
obviously for email this is enough
so he played b5 now he commits to
dispersion then we ship there now this
is not winning
so b5 was actually a mistake which
actually you know one not only one
person still it's a mistake that in the
live commentary Kasparov he was the star
by David Bishop is misplaced on d3
because he saw that King comes to before
we the temple that is actually not yes
yes yes the only place that doesn't win
is actually III NES word by D three wins
so a happens now then V 5 Bishop h5 and
King goes to c6 now okay but the problem
is of course this I think while you look
by the body language I was watching the
game slide I think he missed this check
I think that's what they call missed
because this moment if the bishop is on
h5 the same position after you play King
before I can take I have to take this
that one temple matters a lot when it
pushes the past
Bishop upon King survive we'll never win
because we have the wrong we have the
wrong corner King takes p6 that's the
only way and then here it happens
horrible horrible blunder but with ten
seconds on your clock okay make a
decision here huh well it's not closer
what's your what you're doing with Kings
is really different defense method then
King before we came for just simply
trying to stop with King c3 he did keep
liking me for good king c3 you are
creating a counter-attack and then king
gave four so now it's actually one has
to be careful a six losses to King a
fire now black is a six to hug exposing
it is losing
yeah a 7 you just wait with your bishop
now now we are happy we have a bishop we
don't have a knife you can lose as many
temper as we want and that's not the
problem so but there's only one last
trick here what has black has to be
careful about and that's when you push
the pawn to a7 you have to put the
bishop on it because King gauge 6 is a
threat we don't pay attention to this
kind of force course that's the only
move because King it if you go anywhere
King gauge 6 B visa yeah King King a
16-3 5 b6 King c6 that's how you hold
actually you win or no that's that's a
job that's when see because can get 5 we
should be 7 but this is you see bishop
there and you still scored we tend to
forget about actually that now I want to
put her body so then when Bishop a 867
and then you know I like it this way
stoned again so my favorite way of
making a draw still me
yeah I'd 2015 when I was little working
seriously on chess and a Texas Tech we
used to have this training with our
coach that we would sit and do a lot of
studies and natural whiskey together as
a true skill ring they are big on a
stalemate we did zillions of elements so
whenever I see I found it so well I
think I'm probably he probably had a
link has more than 200 studies in skill
just just drink ok this one is such a
beautiful gem we do not have so much
time to go over go over the whole
material this film interesting Osirian
when the pieces are on the board but I
show you this position again same idea
Bishop to d3
always keep the pawns from point and
then the counter-attack idea here team
to e5 was played white like a king c7
can get four and what makes this
beautiful move King d6 following the
bishop so if you can tie down your
opponent climb down or hair down this is
study Bishop d3 if I go let's say I
don't know I don't see any way so I can
get five for example King just see five
or eight h5
when chilly winds
the King g5 King c7 again this is this
is beautiful now
age five okay do you want to try this
one
well b6 is forced and not in G for teen
b5 we should be freaking get sixty
people like this that's the mutual six
walk and then i4h for King g6 going I
played Bishop d7 a my idea to play h3
bishops King get free and when you
played King G 500 said we shall see that
in the right moment
I don't you actually I don't need that I
can just look in detail
King this is King f3 doesn't work
actually King g5 if I go we should be 7
then you can go King get 5
but King is yes h3 if I take the net for
then King be 5 and a 5 one of the
probably promoted Oh black doesn't those
of obviously because Kim G for M upon
the H probably promoted so I promote the
F on
so this King it's to draw so therefore
but the more challenging one is King f3
so once we get out of these five barn
yes King comes to defy with the temple
teach for
is not or is good enough in five you
come back three five
that's beautiful well actually can
actually sacrifice but you can go also
can get success also draw miss Evans
better takes and then can get five that
you can force it it would be 7 and then
the King goes all the way to beautiful
this is very this is very beautiful and
after can get four can get six okay h4
Oh
mm-hmm yeah that's wrong so it doesn't
matter just Kinkos all over to at 6:00
actually I play all the Tempe within
construction if even I had one more
extra tempo here in the matter you can
go to get six even if you pass them off
to white you still can play can get six
if you have enough Tempe yeah and when I
was filling when I first saw this
position again long time ago what is
interesting is that to study these
positions the Bishop Ussher spawn are
very similar to what diversity calls the
corresponding scores and the - scores if
you learn it with that concept so h5 is
a mind square because well it is the
corresponding square it's corresponds to
b7 if you if you decoy the bishop will
make enough to be suddenly get to age
five that's a draw so that is a that is
an interesting thing in my opinion you
want to learn Bishop and pawn versus
Bishop versus pawn no there's no other
Bishop virtual versus pawn with the
first chapter of their whiskers and game
manual on pawns it's a fascinating work
I like I love the concept maybe the
positions you you could find bigger
materials with the more coverage of
different with more variety of positions
but definitely the weight explains the
concepts is very professional very
interesting so that I would strongly
suggest ok we have the one more position
now this one I discovered was that this
one I think we went over this ah
the last the last thing I have for you
do not over push have you seen this one
today for one I advanced in English can
you believe this one who lacks it I hear
10 seconds only well you know you think
it did this is the moment that you think
there is no absolute in no way that I
can lose a game and that's when things
can go wrong
when you lose objectivity doesn't matter
so and this happens to us more than we
think more often than we think yeah so
King if I was his best try I think
although in a location success is a draw
I think if it was the best practical try
the King was safer but that's what
happened so presently what White King
looks looks looks passive but it
actually has a lot of counter play
through the h4 h5 but you know King get
file actually was the best try but
that's most likely I don't think
everyone I was going to bless to be in
this position because this is a draw but
only one way to make a draw
now Dirk is beautifully cutting the King
now I have to make red mouse check to
kind of push the King to the C files to
stop the problem from just the black get
to play C for King C to C it's going to
be promoted that's for sure and now here
he has to play G for this is the moment
to create a counter play if you watch
one move that could happen to someone
now I have a three you don't have enough
time we have 16 B to take C 3 and the it
is deafening
oh actually Kim D to actually thing to
take C 3 and then you go get a topi 5 C
2 C 2 C 1 that's winning
so kinky - so that was he has to go G
for at moment not even GG because f3 did
that one tempo decides I played it I
believe it over there that those two
pumping advanced enough matters so this
was is Brad best practical chance and
then here f3 was his last chance
obviously G takes a three losses but
then g3 would save the day so that was
his best chance o Keeffe I look c8 there
and then this obviously this is enough
stop the pond and unfortunately 2p4
doesn't work because it doesn't create
any threat just cooking edge for the
both parts will promote at the same time
so and it was a king v3 then the king is
there and I mean time to liquidate upon
sacrifice to afford opponent push the
expo also again this position g4 is not
the only way but the best way and other
ways were practically difficult in 10
seconds on the clock okay hope you guys
had fun I really had to blitz through
through because the announcers were kind
of in-depth and we had I wish I could
give you some more time to think about
it but next week we'll have some more
fun positions as well thank you
[Music]